at some point tomorrow I might devote
some time to talking about how dr.
deborah birx has really become a vector
of donald trump disinformation covering
up his incompetence and suggesting he
has a clue but for today I want to talk
more generally about the fact that
doctors are being pushed out of the
picture when it comes to trumps
Whitehouse coronavirus task force and
that dr. Anthony Fauci has essentially
been disappeared by Donald Trump from
the press briefings over time pouchy has
had a smaller and smaller role he used
to stand on the stage in view of the
cameras then he was on the stage out of
view of the cameras but he would come up
if asked a question then he would sit on
the side and come up if someone had a
question lately he's just not been at
the briefings at all now in conjunction
with this we have a new report that this
is part of a calculated trend where
Donald Trump is going to be pushing
doctors away from the briefings and
instead the briefings as we know we
don't know whether questions will or
won't even be allowed after Thursday's
Fiasco but it is going to be an
economically based briefing and I'm
guessing part of that is if you only
talk about economics you reduce the
chances of wondering aloud about
injecting bleach if there's one person
who should be at every briefing it's dr.
Anthony Fauci he's been running
infectious disease for the US for 35
years he's actually an expert on global
pandemic he's actually a medical doctor
he had been at almost every one of the
first 45 or so briefings and then
suddenly he's gone we know why it's
happening the more of a fool that Trump
makes out of himself the more Anthony
foul he is asked to contradict Donald
Trump and foul she's been careful we've
talked about this before foul she has
said you know I can't jump up every time
Trump says something wrong and interrupt
the president and correct him he would
be fired if he did that and foul she my
guesses has calculated his presence and
his role being maintained in any form is
better than being fired and being
replaced with some kind of total trump
sycophant who may not even really know
anything about it
factious disease so more and more now
ouchy questions are being asked to Trump
you said X and doctor foul Qi said why
can you explain that are you not on the
same page and Trump tends to say I
didn't see it you know I don't know what
Anthony said they are now pulling foul
Qi further away and the defense from the
White House is foul Chi does lots of
other things other than just go to the
briefings he has many other
responsibilities well okay but didn't he
have those responsibilities during the
45 meetings he did attend for more than
a month until he was just disappeared
and we know why it's being done faoud
she continues to say we need to ramp up
testing dramatically Trump says testing
is fine and we have the most in the
world
of course we're 42nd in testing per
capita Trump said in a recent briefing
the virus may not come back in the fall
doctor foul Qi said in that same
briefing we will have coronavirus with
us in the fall and then in the midst of
all this about foul Qi we learn that the
White House wants to just get away from
doctors altogether at the briefing and
talk about economics instead White House
official telling Axios that the press
briefings will continue but that the
virus stuff will take a backseat if you
can imagine while economic stuff and a
more forward-looking message talking
about opening her up and stuff like that
is what we are going to hear so that's
code for stocks and reopening and
v-shaped recovery discussions rather
than death toll vaccinations
therapeutics and it's an election
focused strategy
Axios reports that there are officials
who have told Trump this is hurting you
the press briefings are hurting you and
your polling against Biden in particular
among older Americans is imploding so
the bottom line of the strategy is the
longer this goes on in to worse for
Trump that's clear if the press
briefings become a daily reminder that
Trump just keeps bragging about the same
things every day
the death toll stays high and continues
climbing
that's bad for Trump in November the
November election will be a Trump
referendum but it's going to be more a
referendum on the economy than on the
virus and what I mean by that is Trump
is obviously bungled the
iris responds but changing your vote
based on the virus response does not
seem hugely likely for reasons we
discussed last week with Rachel bitter
coffer on the other hand we know one of
the main things that determines does an
incumbent president get reelected or
removed is the perception of the state
of the economy around the time of the
election this would explain why Trump
would move to an economic message while
doctors continue to be pushed into the
background tomorrow we'll have an
updated report on testing and in the
meantime I would love for dr. fowey to
start doing his own daily updates on
YouTube my guess is he would be fired
for that so what we have is a global
hundred year pandemic the United States
is choosing to sideline the medical
professionals to talk about stocks and
reopening barbershops that's where we
are right now and it's embarrassing
today's program is sponsored in part by
the galaxy Series which is a series of
three books written by a really great
author I thought and I would call the
genre sort of political science fiction
I've really enjoyed the books it looks
at the future it explores what could
happen to Planet Earth if we stay on our
path environmentally it deals with space
travel it takes a sort of deep dive into
political psychology and it's a really
intriguing sort of dystopian look at the
future the stories are told from a
perspective that I think people in the
audience would really appreciate and
there's a ton of really excellent
artwork also that accompanies the books
I read a lot of books in this genre and
I'll tell you these books are very well
written the plot the characters are
compelling if you're someone who likes
politics and sci-fi you'll really like
these books again it's the Galaxy series
check it out for yourself for a limited
time we have a special deal set up where
my audience can get each book for just
99 cents go to david pakman.com slash
galaxy